Suicide Squad was one of the highest-grossing
releases of 2016, setting a new record for
the best ever opening weekend in August and
going on to earn $745 million worldwide.
Critics, however, tore it apart, calling it,
quote, "slipshod" and "a patched-together
mess," among other things.
So how sloppy is Suicide Squad?
Here are just a few examples.
“Worst part of it is they’re gonna blame
us for the whole thing.”
Name changer
Near the start of the film, a character clearly
identified as Admiral Mackenzie isn't sold
on the idea of Task Force X.
Or is it Admiral Olsen?
Ted Whittall's character wears a name tag
identifying him as Mackenzie, which can be
seen several times throughout the scene.
But bizarrely, when the end credits roll,
his character is listed as Admiral Olsen.
It was a nice touch to bring Whittall on board
— hardcore DC fans will remember him as
Suicide Squad leader Rick Flag in the final
season of Smallville — but the confusion
over his character's name shows how little
importance he actually had in the script.
Traveling light
After extorting his client for an extra million
dollars and carrying out a near-impossible
hit, Deadshot makes his escape by jumping
over the edge of the building and rappelling
down the wall.
But before he makes a run for it, he grabs
his big bag of high-tech gear.
But what happens next sticks out like a sore
thumb, once you know about it.
The rucksack he scoops up as he sprints for
the ledge is nowhere to be seen while he's
actually descending — it just disappears
into thin air.
“That’s how I cut and run.”
Kiddie pool
When The Joker dives headfirst into the same
vat of chemicals as his beloved Harley Quinn,
there's something off about the staging.
“Would you die for me?”
“Yes.”
We see from other shots of the vats, and shots
from below the surface of the chemicals, that
the containers are pretty deep.
It's definitely deep enough for a person to
jump into it from a great height and not be
killed.
“That's too easy.
Would you...
Would you live for me?”
Yet after the Joker jumps in to rescue Quinn,
he's able to cradle her in his arms and kiss
her while standing still, which is impossible
— unless he suddenly developed Aquaman-like
swimming powers.
[laughing]
Magic highlights
Harley Quinn is captured by Batman when a
sportscar she's in, driven by the Joker, goes
crashing into the harbor.
Wanting to take them both alive, the Caped
Crusader goes in after them, where he finds
the Joker missing and Quinn unconscious.
“Stupid bat, you’re ruining date night!”
Underwater, Quinn's hair is entirely blonde,
free from the pink and blue highlights she
sports for the majority of the movie.
After Batman pulls her from the water, however,
the highlights inexplicably return.
Moone's mistakes
June Moone is an archaeologist who finds a
totem containing an evil spirit in an ancient
Peruvian temple and is possessed by it, becoming
the Enchantress.
In one scene, Enchantress obtains a binder
from the Weapons Ministry Vault in Tehran.
Written in Persian script, it should open
and be read right-to-left, instead of left-to-right.
But Suicide Squad gets it backwards.
In a later scene, we can see Moone is holding
a beer bottle in her hand as she fiddles with
Rick Flag's shirt.
The angle changes as Moone leans in for a
kiss, and now the bottle is somehow in his
hand.
“I saw it move!”
Elevator edits
During an error-laden elevator ascent, Harley
Quinn is attacked by one of Enchantress' foot
soldiers, who drops down into the elevator
by removing a panel in the ceiling.
Quinn dispatches it with a bullet to the head
and then a second attacker smashes through
the window.
Two glaring mistakes follow: First, the body
of the creature she shot dead seconds earlier
just vanishes.
Then, during the second fight, Quinn runs
up the wall and flips over her assailant,
and when she does, we get a shot of the elevator
ceiling.
The panel that was removed moments ago is
now back in place.
A bad day at the office for the editing team.
Peeping toms
There's another Harley Quinn-related goof
during the scene in which the Squad get out
of their prison rags and get suited up.
As she slips into something a little more
comfortable, the camera pans up Margot Robbie's
body slowly as if to mimic the leering of
the men nearby.
Hardly anyone is around Quinn as she squeezes
into her "Daddy's Lil Monster" t-shirt, yet
in the next shot, she's suddenly surrounded
by gawking men.
A funny reveal, but it makes zero sense.
"What?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!